ne demandez pas ce que votre pays peut
faire pour vous demandez vous ce que
vous pouvez faire pour votre pays
une célèbre phrase du président
américain john fitzgerald kennedy pour
sa conférence face à des lycéens
l'eurodéputé jean marie cavada voulu
transmettre cet état d'esprit s'engager
pour la société si l'on veut que les
choses aillent mieux il faut se lever de
son fauteuil il faut faire quelque chose
pour le collectif et leur première étape
s'est naturellement femmes et les
élections européennes parce que beaucoup
des lois auxquelles vous obéissez les
uns et les autres
plus de la moitié viennent de bruxelles
alors il faut s'entraîner pour son
intervention au lycée marie-curie
l'union européenne étaient au coeur des
échanges ses valeurs son fonctionnement
mais aussi des améliorations à apporter
face à des lycéens ayant leur regard sur
la question je pense que c'est important
au final qu'on soit unie autour d'une
union parce que ça rassemble les gens
aient forcément face à la montée en
puissance de la chine par exemple
aujourd'hui et la puissance américaine
finalement on est tous dans le même bain
dans le même bateau on est tous en
europe etc
et c'est important qu'on se bat tous
unis en france on n'est pas non plus un
pays très grand donc en soi même si la
france est fondée et fort ce qui est
très important
ça ne suffira pas à sauver notre planète
malheureusement donc il faut qu'on le
soit sur une échelle qu'ils soient plus
grande
nos élèves sont déjà citoyen parce
qu'elle vote ou de futurs citoyens
il est hyper important qu'en dehors de
toute part tidianisme est prise de
position is et un éclairage sur les
enjeux de notre société surtout en ce
moment pour pouvoir prendre des
positions saine sereine et éclairé jean
marie cavada devrait terminer son
troisième mandat sans le renouveler
d'après sa promesse initiale
sauf si une urgence absolue le pousse à
se représenter